jean pierre foucault n'est pas connu
pour prendre très souvent position
politiquement il faut croire que ces
dernières heures l'animateur qui est
confiné chez lui à carry-le-rouet n'a
pas pu s'empêcher de réagir face à une
vidéo qu'il a vu sur les réseaux sociaux
dans cet extrait réalisé par un
internaute on peut découvrir un montage
vidéo regroupant toutes les déclarations
médiatiques des membres du gouvernement
de médecins spécialistes qui il ya
plusieurs semaines se presser sur les
plateaux pour minimiser l'importance du
corona virus et il va pas y avoir une
épidémie en france ne vont jamais
envisagé la fermeture totale les
français qui sont quand même très
affolés par la à l'épidémie médiatique
psychotique
on va pourquoi on leur dénie ray le
droit d'aller voter fait un bios de plus
que de propagation du virus dans la
population sont très faibles des images
embarrassantes pour le gouvernement qui
aujourd'hui répète à longueur de prises
de paroles qu'ils avaient anticipé
l'importance du coc vite 19 dès le
départ effarant c'est par ce simple
message et la publication de la vidéo
que l'animateur a réagi à ces images que
nombreux ont découvert grâce à lui une
publication qui risque de faire beaucoup
parler
alors avant qu'on donne la parole à jean
pierre parce que c'est vrai que jean
pierre qui a pris la parole sur twitter
hier moi je me suis dit c'est vrai que
nous on est tous qu'on finit on se lâche
un petit peu kester pansement à sa main
il a raison parce que si on résume
l'histoire en trois journées passées de
tout va bien c'est l'équipe est à
confiner à la maison et une crise
mondiale c'est vrai que ça s'est passé
très vite et en trois jours honnêtement
si on trouve fait le film il ya eu un
problème
j'ai alors je suis d'accord sur le fond
je partage tout ce que dit jean pierre
mais personnellement et je reconnais le
mérite de dire ce qu'ils pensent et sans
leader personnellement je n'aurais pas
polémiquer avant la sainte cette guerre
de cette crise majeure
voilà moi j'aurais différé mais sur le
sont tout ce qui est dit est juste il
plaint de déclarations contradictoires
donc à rien à dire sur le son
directement des rituels on va donner à
ton frère rené malleville je trouve
qu'il a absolument raison parce qu'il
s'agit pas de dire aussi l'union sacrée
mais il ya tellement de progrès qu'on
est obligé de définir les
responsabilités de ceux qui grâce à
cause de qui il ya ce problème
il a raison mais en tout cas c'est pas
du polémique cédé qu'un staff
j'en fais reconduit à nous marquer ça
demain ça nous montre encore on va
laisser jean pierre agert mots jean
pierre quétu moins d'inscriptions gens
perdent alors oui simplement joue
déterrage il que moi je ne polémique pas
c'est simplement qu'ils seraient non
simplement dit effarant a je crois que
c'est par la valise est réel j'ai 2546
euros et j'ai simplement que j'ai vu le
montage que j'ai vu moi il ya une règle
d'or bien que nous restons très bien
ceux qui savent ne parlent pas il ne
faut pas parler quand on sait en
revanche ceux qui parlent ne savent pas
et ça a été terrible parce que quand
vous incitez michel cymes quand on lui
dit est ce que vous croyez que c'est
grave il dit non je suis pas très
inquiet non sans virus comme un nom
d'une petite grippe etc
mais c'est profondément scandaleux ne
dit rien ne dit rien quand la part
extrêmement dangereuses non soyez
méticuleux dans le choix des mots et
surtout soyez méticuleux dans le choix
des silences
moi je suis assez d'accord avec son père
parce qu'il ya des paroles qui porte
mine de rien et franchement au départ
quand on nous a dit c'est une petite
grippette
on avait pourquoi les jeunes qui sortent
encore pourquoi les jeunes ils disent
oui le moi c'est moi je suis pas touché
et à son singly pet
ils ont dit quoi ils ont les premiers
mots dans la tête donc ils disent oui il
ya des failles à dire franchement il ya
des paroles qui pensent préfère un mec
qui dit écoutez pour l'instant on peut
pas on peut pas se prononcer on va voir
comment ça évolue en chine mais vaut
mieux prendre toutes les précautions
plutôt que de vouloir voilà parler
absolument et donner son avis pas là
jean pierre je pense que j'ai c'est ce
que tu voulais dire aussi exactement
exactement imaginer qu'on dit allez-y
vous pouvez sauté de la falaise et trois
jours un peu non je pense que la falaise
voilà bah écoutez moi je les dénonce
depuis le départ mais après
de toute façon on s'est moqué de
l'italie on s'est moqué de l'espagne
comme si c'était des pays du tiers monde
quand on voyait en italie tous les gens
qui mouraient aux visées oui mais vous
comprenez nous rappelle système et tout
ça mais non pendant des semaines et des
semaines on a essayé de dire y'a pas de
base qui a pas de solution hydro
alcoolique et ses jambières pourquoi et
guillet ce que tout le monde pense tout
bas
maintenant un bon coup de gueule ça fait
du bien même si communion nationale
c'est vrai d'art le président et les
politiques doivent le faire mais après
tout le monde à faire parce que si les
français ont l'impression de son bateau
télé ont dit ce qu'ils pensaient main
mais bien la façon d'être
on est complètement déconnecté juste
remplir ses chants vraiment c'est pas un
coup de gueule il a relayé un montage ce
qui la fait chanter son amour étage
c'est vous fait il est édifiant c'est
juste voilà c'est sûr que c'est édifiant
mais on se retient un petit peu là de
montrer toute la colère qu'on a
évidemment que ça allait nous péter au
visage
on le voyait venir et je ne sais pas
pourquoi jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout et
heureusement et c'est les médecins qui
ont dénoncé est arrivé là laurent
laurent
lorsque l'on parle vraiment de ce qui
s'est passé avant jean-pierre tt confiné
avec je crois que tu est confiné avec
avec ta fille aussi avec virginie et
nous sommes à carry le rouet c'est que
tu me manques je n'embrasse virginie que
j'aime fort aussi c'est la famille ça
vraiment et vous savez que vous me
manquez - jean-pierre tu me manques fort
et virgin et au seul je vous aime très
fort les deux vraiment ça c'est vraiment
de la ferme ici comme sarkozy j'aime les
gens vont continuer merci on t'embrasse
aujourd'hui arriver un génie je t'aime
fort ma chérie tu me manques je vous
embrasse mecheri merci d'avoir été là